NARRATOR: There are a couple
of things in this scene that
seem unusual, but
one thing sticks out
more than everything else.
The building's
foundation appears
to fall away into oblivion.
It looks like something out
of an M.C. Escher picture
or an Indiana Jones movie.
The scene was
captured by this guy.
BRYAN TIGHE: Hi, my
name is Bryan Tighe.
I'm a software developer
and an amateur photographer.
NARRATOR: Bryan was
traveling with his wife
through Lalibela, a mountainous
region in northern Ethiopia.
Bryan took this photo on a visit
to a church that was actually
carved into a hill.
BRYAN TIGHE: To reach
this particular church,
we walked along a shallow ravine
that eventually became deeper.
The trail moved up to the
left side of the ravine,
and then we rounded
a corner to the left,
revealing a church to our right
on the other side of this now
very deep chasm.
NARRATOR: The church
is one of several
in Lalibela with the same
unusual construction.
Instead of being built
from the ground up,
these structures were
carved from the surrounding
volcanic rock.
From the huge monolithic
block, windows and doors
were carved out.
And inside, an extensive
network of passages,
ceremonial rooms, and catacombs.
BRYAN TIGHE: The detail on the
craftsmanship were amazing.
And once inside, we
watched the priests slowly
emerge from a back
room carrying candles,
a large Bible, and a variety
of other sacred objects.
They were all singing
and chanting in unison,
and only the candles
lit the interior, which
created a very moody scene.
NARRATOR: There are
13 monolithic churches
carved into the rocks, which
were commissioned by King
Lalibela in the 12th century.
When Jerusalem fell to
the Muslims in 1187,
the devoutly
Christian king decided
to construct a new Jerusalem
in his own homeland.
Today thousands make
the journey to see
these astounding
man-made monuments.
BRYAN TIGHE: Seeing
this church and all
of the others for the
first time was a shock,
because it is just so remarkable
how all of these churches
were constructed out of
solid rock, and so long ago.
Visiting Lalibela is like
stepping back in time
into another place,
another culture,
and another way of life.
NARRATOR: Hey, everyone.
If you'd like to be
featured on our show,
send us a link to
your photography
website below in the comments.
If you don't have a site,
and are looking to make one,
get a domain name at domain.com.
It's affordable,
reliable, and easy to use.
And because you
watch our show, you
can get 20% off new domains,
web hosting, and email
by using the code "happened"
when you check out.
When you think domain
names, think domain.com.
For more This Happened Here,
check out this episode.
And thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]